flip top centrifuge tubes are one of the  easiest types of tools to use when you  don't want to deal with much hassle with  opening and closing it perfect for when  your sample doesn't require a high  amount of G-Force to separate and  perfect for applications that are  non-hazardous now these centrifuge tubes  are designed with a conical bottom to  make it easier for you to extract Your  solution our centrifuge tubes can handle  12 000 G's of Max Force and are created  with a high quality polypropylene  material to prevent sample contamination  there's also a large writing patch and  graduated marks for easy identification  of your sample